من بيروت ينضم الينا عبر الهاتف اسامه
حمدان القيادي في حركه حماس سيد اسامه هل
الوضع فعلا لدى حركه حماس بالنسبه لهذا
المقترح افضل من
السابق بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحقيقه لابد من التاكيد على ثلاثه او
ثلاث مسائل المساله الاولى نعم هناك جهود
تبذل من الاشقاء من اجل الوصول الى وقف
لاطلاق النار هذا هو موقف حماس وهناك جهود
قطريه ومصريه في هذا السياق كما لا يخفى
على احد النقطه الثانيه الحركه ابلغت كل
الوسطاء وبوضوح ان اولويتنا اليوم هي وقف
العدوان على قطاع غزه وان اي موضوع اخر
سياتي لاحقا لهذا الموضوع وقف العدوان على
غزه بشكل حاسم ونهائي كما صدر امس من
مواقف واضحه سواء عن الحركه في مؤتمرها
الصحفي او عن كتائب القسام في حديث الاخ
المجاهد ابو عبيده المتحدث باسم الكتائب
شعبنا لا ينتظر هدنا مؤقته او مراحل جزئيه
شعبنا صامد وثابت ويضحي ولكنه يتطلع الى
انهاء العدوان ولذلك لا بد ان ينتهي
العدوان هنا ياتي السؤال لماذا تصدر مثل
هذه ال المعلومات من الجانب الاسرائيلي
هناك عاملين ل لهذا الامر العامل الاول
الجانب الاسرائيلي حتى اللحظه يعاني من
ضغط في شارعه نتيجه عدد القتلى من هؤلاء
الاسرى وادراك العائلات والجمهور
الاسرائيلي ان نتنياهو يخوض المعركه
لحسابات شخصيه لا يهمه فيها من يقتل من
هؤلاء الاسرى او حتى من جنود الاحتلال وهو
يحاول بمثل هذه التسريبات تنفيس الاحتقان
في الشارع وتنفيس الضغوط على حكومته التي
تعاني من ازمات وربما توشك ان تنهار وهنا
تاتي النقطه الثانيه هو يحاول ان يحافظ
على تماسك حكومه فشلت في تحقيق اهداف
عمليتها العسكريه واذا ما حصل لها انهيار
فان ذلك يعني هزيمه اسرائيليه حقيقيه لهذا
انا اؤكد وبوضوح انه لا حديث كما تسرب
اسرائيل الحديث يتركز من طرفنا ومن طرف
المقاومه على وقف كامل ونها للعدوان على
قطاع غزه قبل البحث في موضوع تبادل
الاسراء الذي يجب ان ياتي لاحقا لاغاثه
غزه ايضا واطلاق مشروع اعمارها كذلك هذا
هو موقفكم الثابت كما تقول ولكن هل جرى
طرح هذا المقترح عليكم 40 الى الافراج عن
40 الى 50 محتجز اسرائيلي
مقابل وقف اطلاق النار او هدنه لمده شهر
هل هذا المقترح طرح اصلا على قياده
حماس الافكار التي قدمت ليس فيها مثل هذه
الفكره بالضبط ونحن لا نتحدث عن الافكار
لاننا نحترم جهود الوسطاء وايضا نؤكد
للوسطاء موقفنا الواضح الذي بات مفهوما
ليس من الوسطاء وحسب مفهوما ومتقبل على
مستوى دولي واقليمي وهناك ادراك الى ان
حجم الجريمه الاسرائيليه يجب ان يتوقف وان
هذه الجريمه لا يمكن ان تستمر الاسرائيلي
يريد ان يواصل الجريمه ويريد ان ينفس
ازماته الداخليه على حساب الشعب الفلسطيني
وبالتالي هو يحاول ان يسرب مثل هذه
الاخبار غير الصحيحه او يحاول ان يلوي عنق
بعض الاقتراحات بطريقه
تناسبه هل لنا ان نعرف الان ما هو
الاقتراح الاقرب
اي الى
افكار ومطالب حركه حماس حاليا وهو مطروح
لتفاوض الحقيقه الافكار هي ع محل حوار
ولذلك لا يمكن ان اتكلم عن فكره متبلوره
بشكل كامل ونهائي هناك افكار يطرحها
الوسطاء هناك افكار نطرحها نحن لكن العمود
الفقري لهذه الافكار كما قلت هو الذهاب
الى وقف كامل وشامل
للعدوان يوني على قطاع غزه هذه هي القاعده
الاساس التي نعمل عليها الاسرائيلي ربما
لا يعجبه ذلك لا يريد ذلك لكنه يدرك في
ذات الوقت ان استمرار العدوان لم يعد يحقق
له النتائج التي ارادها او التي يوهم
شارعه انها ستتحقق وبالذات في قضيتين قضيه
العمليه العسكريه خاصه مع الخسائر التي
يتكبدها في الايام الاخيره وثانيا مع قضيه
الاسرى الذين بداوا يتساقط بعضهم نتيجه
السلوك الاسرائيلي لهذا نحن نقول وبوضوح
وقف العدوان هو المقدم الشعب الفلسطيني لا
يتطلع الى وقف جزئي وانما وقف كامل ونهائي
وهذه مسؤوليتنا وهذا التزامنا وبعد ذلك
يمكن الحديث في اي قضايا اخرى هل تعتقد
حماس انها قادره على
فرض وقف لاطلاق النار شامل قبل البحث ب
مساله اي استئناف المفاوضات بشان
التبادل نحن مقتنعون اننا نملك من الادوات
والامكانات ما ما يحقق لنا ذلك ولولا هذا
لما ذهبنا في هذا الاتجاه ونحن ندرك تماما
ان ما يفعله الاسرائيلي الان
هو محاوله الخروج من مازق الداخلي الذي
فرضه تعنت نتنياهو ولا يمكن ان يخرج منه
على حساب الشعب الفل فلسطيني خروجه من هذا
المازق له طريق واحد فقط هو وقف العدوان
وتقديم التنازلات المناسبه لاجراء صفقه
تبادل للاسرى بعد ذلك تقول بان هناك تفهم
من الوسطاء لهذا المطلب
ام هل هل يمكن ان نفهم اكثر ماذا يعني
ذلك الوسطاء لا يحاولون فرض رؤيه على حماس
او على المقاومه هم يحولون المساعده في
الوصول الى نهايه لهذا
العدوان وحمايه الشعب الفلسطيني من
استمرار النزيف نتيجه هذا العدوان ولذلك
من الطبيعي ان يتفهم الوسطاء ان وقف
العدوان هو الاولويه عند
المقاومه طيب في في هذا المجال ماذا لو
رفضت اسرائيل وانت تقول ان اسرائيل حتى
الان
ترفض هذا الامر بالمطلق
انا اظن ان نتنياهو لا يملك رفاهيه الرفض
المستمر الكل يعرف ان الشارع يتحرك ويضغط
بقوه وهناك شعور في في في الشارع
الاسرائيلي ان نتنياهو لا يعبا بهؤلاء
الاسرى ولا يهمه ان قتلوا وايضا هناك ازمه
داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه ناشئه عن
تجاذبات داخليه حول الصلاحيات بين مجلس
الحرب وبين الحكومه المصغره وبين الحكومه
الواسعه وكل هذه التجاذبات تضيق الخناق
على نتنياهو اضيف الى ذلك ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي اليوم وهو يدفع لواء سابعا في
معركه خانيونس المتعسر ادائه فيها انما
يقدم رساله واضحه ان الجيش ايضا يعاني من
مازق في معركته في الميدان نتيجه صمود
الشعب وبساله المقاومه كل هذه عوامل اعتقد
لا تعطي نتنياهو
الرفاهيه في ان يستمر في الرفض يدرك
نتنياهو اكثر من اي طرف اخر ان ان عليه ان
يقدم الثمن المطلوب لكنه يحاول المناوره
باسلوب ساذج وهو تسريب اخبار كاذبه
للاعلام يظن ان من خلالها بامكانه ان ينفذ
حاله الاحتقان التي تحيط به داخليا اسامه
حمدان القيادي في حركه حماس شكرا جزيلا لك